- [Voiceover] Now I come
to another configuration
for an op-amp.
And it's partially drawn here.
And I'm gonna talk about this
as I draw the rest of this circuit in.
So this is gonna be made
from a resistor configuration
that looks like this.
We'll have a resistor on the top.
And this will be v-out,
as we did before.
And now we have a connection like this
and the connection here to ground.
This terminal is the minus terminal;
and this terminal is
the positive terminal.
This is upside down from
what we've done so far.
But now pay particular attention here,
this one has the minus on top.
So now we have R1 and R2.
And this is v-in.
In particular, what we wanna
do is find an expression
for v-out
as a function of v-in.
All right.
And in this video, I'm
gonna do it the hard way.
And what the hard way
means is we're gonna do
all the algebra to do this.
And then in the next video I'm
gonna show you the easy way.
The easy way is really fun to learn,
and it really helps to see
it the hard way one time
just so you appreciate the easy way.
The other thing we get to do in this video
is we'll do the algebra and
we'll see how this gain,
we take advantage of this
gain to make some assumptions.
OK, so let's go after this.
Let's develop an expression
for v-out in terms of v-in.
First, let's write some things
we know about v-out, OK?
We know that v-out equals A times...
Now, it's usually v-plus minus v-minus.
This is v-plus.
This is v-minus.
Usually the expression here
is v-plus minus v-minus.
And since v-plus is zero,
we're just gonna put in minus v-minus.
This is equivalent to saying
that v-minus equals
minus v-out over A.
So what else can we
write for this circuit?
OK, let's look at these resistors.
Let's call this plus and minus vR1;
and we'll call this one plus minus vR2.
So there's a current flowing
here, and that we'll call I.
So I'm just gonna use Ohm's Law on R1 here
and write an expression for I.
I
equals
vR1
over
R1.
Right?
Another way I can write that.
What's this voltage here?
This is v-minus.
So I can write this in terms
of v-minus, and that equals
v-in
minus v-minus
over R1.
That's the current going
through this guy here.
Now I'm gonna use something special.
I'm gonna use something special
that I know about this amplifier.
What I know about an op-amp
is that this current here
is equal to zero.
There's no current that
flows into an ideal op-amp.
So I could take advantage of that.
What that means is that I flows in R2.
So let me write and expression for I
based on what I find
over here, based on R2.
I can write I equals,
let's do it, it's vR2
over R2.
And I can write vR2 as:
v-minus
minus v-out
over R2.
All right, so I took
advantage of the zero current
flowing in here to write
an expression for current
going all the way through.
All right.
So now we're gonna set these
two equal to each other.
Now we're gonna make these
Let me go over here and do that.
V-in
minus v-minus
over R1.
That equals this term here,
which is v-minus minus v-not,
v-out rather,
over R2.
How many variables do we have here?
We have v-out, we have
v-in, and we have v-minus.
And what I want is just v-out and v-in,
so I'm gonna try to eliminate v-minus;
and the way I'm gonna do that
is this expression over here.
We're gonna take advantage
of this statement right here
to replace minus v-out over A.
So I'll do that right here.
So let me rewrite this.
It's gonna be
v-in
minus
minus v-out over A,
so I get to make this a plus,
and this becomes v-out over A
all divided by R1.
And that equals...
V-minus is minus v-out over A
minus v-out
over R2.
All right, let's roll down a little bit,
get some room,
and we'll keep going.
What am I gonna do next?
Next, I'm gonna multiply both sides by A,
just to get A out of the bottom there.
So now I get
A times v-in
plus v-out
over R1
equals
minus v-out
minus Av-out
over R2.
There's a lot of algebra
here, but trust me,
it's gonna simplify down
here in just a minute.
All right, so now I'm gonna break this up
into separate terms so I
can handle them separately.
Av-in over R1
plus v-out over R1
equals minus v-out over R2
minus Av-out over R2.
Let's change colors so we don't get bored.
Next, what I'm gonna do is start to gather
the v-out terms on one side
and the v-in terms on the other side.
So that means that this v-out term here
is gonna go to the other side.
Av-in
over R1
equals,
let's do minus v-out over R2
minus Av-out over R2.
And this term comes over as
minus v-out over R1.
Haven't made any sign errors yet.
Now let me clear the R1.
We'll multiply both sides by R1.
Av-in
equals
R1 over R2
minus
v-not
R1 over R2
Av-not
minus v-not.
Yeah, the R1s cancel on that last term.
All right.
Av-in
equals.
Out of here I can factor
this term here.
Minus R1 over R2 times v-not,
I can factor that out of here and here.
So I can do minus R1
over R2 v-not
times
one plus A
minus v-not.
So let's take a look at this expression
and use our judgement to
decide what to do next.
Now, because A is so huge,
that means that this first
term is gonna be gigantic
compared to this v-not term here.
V-not is some value like five volts
or minus five volts or
something like that.
And A times this is something like 100,000
or 200,000, something like that.
It dwarfs this v-not, so I'm
gonna ignore this for now.
I'm just gonna cross that out,
and we'll move forward
without that little v-not
on the end of the expression.
This is after we've left that out.
Now we have v-in on this side.
And I'm gonna take A
over to the other side.
One plus A over A.
And this is a point where we
get to use our judgement again.
Again, A is a huge number, like a million;
and so A plus one is a million and one.
That fraction is really
really close to one,
so I'm gonna ignore it; I'm
gonna just say it's one.
So we'll send this one to one.
And let me roll up a little bit more,
just to have a little bit more room.
Now what we have is what?
V-in
equals minus R1
over R2
times v-out.
And I want the expression
just in terms of v-out,
so I'm gonna spin this around,
and we'll get v-out equals minus R2
over R1 times v-in.
So this is what our
op-amp is doing for us.
It basically says v-out is the ratio
of two resistors times v-in.
The gain of the overall circuit
is determined by the ratio
of those two resistors.
And very importantly, there's
a minus sign in front of it.
The minus sign came all the way through.
Again, let me sketch
the circuit real quick.
We had the minus sign on top.
There's v-out.
And there was R1 and R2.
And the positive input,
the non-inverting input,
was connected to ground.
OK?
So this pattern with the resistor going
over the top to the minus,
this is called a inverting
op-amp.
And this is a really familiar
pattern in op-amp circuits.
You can see these on schematics,
and you'll be designing these on your own.
So this was quite a bit of algebra it took
to get down to this point,
and in the next video I'm gonna show you
a really easy way to shortcircuit all this
and be able to do this
analysis really quickly;
and that's called the virtual ground.